hey everybody it's mike from order flows
and in today's video i'm going to talk
about imbalances in the order flow okay
so imbalances occur when you have more
aggressive either buying that would be a
buying a balance or more aggressive
selling that would be a selling
imbalance now how do you measure it well
you measure it based on the volume
that's trading in the two-way auction
right we know we have a bid at one price
and an offer at the next higher price so
say the market is five bit at six
you know
20 lots trade on the bid 150 trade on
the offer
you would call that a buying imbalance
because only 20 versus 150 now people
generally use a ratio of about four to
one some people use three to one some
people use
five to one some people use six to one
it really depends on what you want to
consider an imbalance in the marketplace
but sort of the industry standard
if there is one
is about four to one and
when you start seeing more than one
imbalance
in a bar that's time to pay attention
now a stacked imbalance is when you have
um
you know three or more imbalances
stacked neatly on top of each other so
you know a bind a balance at five buying
a balance at six or buying a balance at
seven you'd consider that a stacked
imbalance and it's important to make
note of where these occur
because you know markets have memory
right liquidity has memory
so when a market comes back those levels
it can give you a good opportunity to
either get long or get short and if
you're looking at a normal bar chart
right
all you see is just the open the high
the low the close of the bar and when
you're looking at a candlestick chart
it'll either print it red or green you
know green for a bar that closed up
uh you know from where it opened or red
if it closed lower than where it opened
normal bar charts
open high low close charts just you know
you're just looking at the bar there's
no callers then sometimes people say
well you know there's so much price
action you can see on a candlestick
chart not really you know you're just
looking at the relation of
the open
to the close
and you're seeing where the high and the
low is made but if you're just looking
at a normal candlestick chart like this
you don't understand why a market pulls
back to a level why does the market at 9
905 pull back to 39.75
right well because it references you
know this level from earlier when the
number came out
okay or why does the market pull back to
you know
91 here and then sell off well it's
because it's referencing something that
happened earlier
and usually there's something in the
order flow right something interesting
happened right so if you remember
you know friday
the second was the non-farm payroll
right big bar up right and you had this
nice stacked imbalance appearing right
in that middle of the bar right around
the 3973 to 74 area right boom boom boom
number count a lot of aggressive buying
you don't see a whole heck a lot of
liquidity there market just shot
straight up
okay
but you're left with this stacked buying
and balance here as you can see this big
green
line coming through the chart
and what happens later market goes up
comes off comes right back down to 39.74
imagine if you knew of that level as
being
a piece of market generated information
you can trade around it right all you
got to do is you just throw in a bid
here right around the 74 you know a stop
at 73
and look what happens it's holding it's
holding one bar two bars three bars four
bars then it rallies from 74 all the way
up to 94
in about 10 15 minutes
okay simple right just like look at this
little stacked imbalance here it only
lasted for one two three bars right up
in here
but it's holding imagine you could buy
it here at 86 right it rallies up into
the 90s right
again a quick five points
here's a stack selling a balance this
one failed it just you know just kept
going up it took it out and kept going
higher okay i mean you know not all
trades work out i wish i could say that
this is one of those trades you could go
um mortgage your house for and trade
them every single time i mean sometimes
you know markets conditions change
and mark you know these aggressive
sellers that were here earlier they're
no longer here they're not interested in
selling anymore
all right here's one right market sold
off came off it's kind of holding this
level around 81
you know it held got a little bit
through it before rallying back up
you know if you look at um
this was a level from the day before but
if you're looking at you know this level
we hit our high up here after the number
came out
and you know around this uh what is that
96 97 area you got a stacked selling a
balance came in market sold off rallied
right back up to where 96 97
and then just went sideways on you but
you know again it's going to give you a
nice opportunity for a scalp you know
honestly to see you know trades like
this work out where it came right down
to 74 held it perfectly then rallied 20
points is um
not normal i i you know
i don't want you guys thinking that all
i got to do is buy and sell stack
imbalances
the you know you guys still got to take
market context into it and use risk
management but it gives you something
that you can you know build the trading
uh strategy around okay so again i don't
want you think oh you know mike's just
showing me the perfect example i mean
let's take the previous day
you know and i prefer to look at them
the stacked imbalances during the u.s
sessions as opposed to you know the the
overnight sessions where there's less
volume
you know here's a couple there's two in
this bar buying a balance buying and
balance stacked buying a bounce deck
buying and balance the first one came
sort of went sideways on you the second
one came right back into it
overshot the imbalance by just one tick
before again shooting up almost you know
over 40 points 20 points from the
you know the 22 23 up to 43
right just you know pretty much nice
methodical move um straight up here's a
stack selling a balance just went
sideways on you if it didn't stop you
out up here just went sideways on you
you know as a trader you got to decide
is this market paying me or is it just
going sideways on me here it is just
going sideways on you
you know so you're going to see these
you know
in pretty much all markets right here's
a nice stack selling a balance came in
came right back up to the level again
got past it by just one tick before it
sold off
right people always
look at order flow as a tool to help you
find levels and these are generated by
what's actually trading in the market
right it's not based off of some
mathematical
calculation other than you know do you
have more aggressive buying than
aggressive selling in here i have more
aggressive selling than aggressive
buying well okay it's coming in at what
level 39
39 21 okay if the market comes back up
there and it's gonna
not penetrate it too much and if there's
going to be some aggressive selling
still coming in after we get up that
level i probably want to be short right
and you can see stack uh here's the
selling of balance here's a selling a
balance selling a balance selling
balance okay okay yeah it's probably a
good opportunity to get short there
so
again you know stack buying and balances
stacks selling and balances you know are
great levels to key around right here's
a stack buying a balance market just
sort of went sideways try to put a
half-hearted rally in but just going
sideways okay now as a trader probably
in the next video i'm going to talk
about signs of realizing a trade is not
working out that a trade is going
sideways that maybe you should
realize that hey you know what i got to
get out of this trade and and wait for
something you know more important to
come in to
give the market a push
so
again just you know look for stack
buying and balances tax selling it
balances it's not brain surgery you know
everyone wants to try to make the market
something bigger than it is you know
come up with all these
algos all that stuff when you just trade
what's right in front of you right
here's the stack buying a balance okay
doesn't work out fine you just wait for
the next trade
right now this is e-minis let's take a a
look at
you know another market um
i don't know let's go to
crude oil okay just give me a second
here for the chart to pop up
okay so here's the crude chart um let's
make this a little bit easier to read
scrunch it down a bit uh
scroll this in here
and just really quick sort of go back
how crude has been
cruise volatility and crude has picked
up
obviously this year with everything
going on in the world
but you know look at this beautiful
level right here this came out again
right around that number time right
non-farm payrolls
just after 7 30. you can see it came
right down to the level right here 88
20 to 25
and a nice move up
okay
so again you know it doesn't matter what
market you're looking at you just want
to be looking for
stacked imbalances either stack buying
and balances stack selling the balances
and again you know if you're looking at
normal bar charts you're not going to
see
where imbalances are coming in on the
market right it's only on these
footprint charts that you can see these
areas where you have stacked buying and
balance from earlier or stacked selling
and balance from earlier
so you know i'll end it there for today
you know i hope you found this video
useful again you know if you like these
videos and you want to see more be sure
to you know subscribe to the channel hit
the button below and obviously like the
video you know it keeps you know vanity
it makes me feel good that people are
liking my video
and you know again you know just
read what the market is telling you look
at what the market is telling you and
trade it right again you know
people like to over complicate things
you don't need to right just trade what
is right in front of you based off of
what's trading right now right that's
the whole beauty of order flow order
flow is best used
as soon as it becomes available as soon
as this information
becomes available right when that number
came out like okay i got a level here
okay
and it's whole you know it's next thing
you know it's coming out 7 30 it's you
know eight o'clock
it's nine o'clock you know 8 30
8 45
and you know this level from earlier is
being drawn on your chart okay let's see
what happens if it comes down into it oh
it's holding okay chances are it's
holding
chances are it's going to rally
so
anyway guys
i could go on for hours about overflow
it's just so fascinating so
thanks for watching this video and be
sure to
check out the next ones bye